Self-propelled tripod type middle camera shooting start
Where is the subject?
The close-up of the driving wheel is a three-page
repeat.  Cut
Repeat the same background It
's humiliating Okay Cut out the decided pose in particular
Yo
listen Depending on where you're moving, a new past sticking close to the
background A sexual act that shifts the background slightly
I want
to send you a letter too It's a long time, just one more piece of salty cutter It's a trick of a
popular restaurant to avoid a rut by starting a daily menu with a standard menu
Everyone loves clouds in the blue sky Everyone loves summer movies  Clouds in the sky The
background is easy if the character's bag is empty If it's a manga,
there are some frames with white backgrounds Why is the background of all cuts drawn in detail in anime in the first place
?  It's beautiful
Rossoku I
dare to create the atmosphere of the camera There are changes in exposure even on people, even if
they can't move.
No, even if the
drawing is good, it's still a story, and it's already cool.